Andrew Tate Andrew Tate to entertain
virtually every tech company on the
planet banned him so I became the most
violent person on the planet with all
the algorithms working against me
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
and I'm here to learn something new
today I'll help you with that if you've
got something to say just say it don't
beat around the bush feel like it's
self-accountability it is a ticking Time
Bomb until Society teaches you a lesson
meant that I want to change they're not
accountable for themselves but everybody
wants to go and find these top earning
money I want Chris Brown and then
they'll go try to get Chris Brown then
Chris Brown sheep I am devastated well
what the [ __ ] do you think is gonna
happen Andrew take my son's older than
him so I don't give a damn who he is I
need a degree of authority to sometimes
come along and say cook my [ __ ]
dinner shut up
because the Western world has collapsed
in real time and it's a failed Society
one of the reasons is to fail Society is
because of the over sexualization
especially females as a whole a woman
who can suck good [ __ ] well don't
come and talk to me my [ __ ] dick is
vile it's disgusting I don't want to
hear that [ __ ] this Chase for state is
that they will never get why don't you
just find a regular nine to five person
that's gonna look after you you can be
his Queen that's status is cheating
morally correct yes it depends yes
how can you say that are you okay with
your woman cheating on you then
absolutely not that's all right now
oh my gosh she was at the advertising
when we done the introduction I am
single doing interviews so far he's
talking a sense thank you very much
thank you Kevin pick me right
who said pick me
I'm here to see if Mr Tate can learn
something from me but what would I do
[Music]